[Music]
show begins with 26 seconds of walking
and i'm not really interested in seeing
the book of boba fett's squid game
person escaping from bad guys has a cell
phone but can't find a signal cliche
this drawing over here seems to
foreshadow the final game and shows just
two people fighting but how can they
guarantee there only be two people in
the final while still maintaining the
charade of equality in theory everyone
could have survived the previous game if
they were lucky enough why did you do
that is gihon seriously asking this
question i'm not saying yay to murder
but i understand how this game is played
and i'm not sure gee hun does how has he
survived this far i don't think
intelligence or skill has played a
factor it's because you always gotta
open your mouth and ask something
idiotic hey leave him alone some of us
make a career out of doing just that
just a dimwit who lives off his mother
but you're with me in this place isn't
that interesting gehan would be the
front man at tv sins why destroy the air
tank i get they've got a boat but that's
a perfectly serviceable air tank that
they could use in the future throw it in
the boat if you don't want him to
retrieve it the date on this phone says
june 29th which makes no sense geon's
daughter's birthday was june 8th and he
went into the squid games the very next
day how's it taking three weeks to get
through five games they had some off
days between games and most importantly
how does the phone still have 12 battery
after three weeks i'll call you again
soon june ho is proving to be just
another [ __ ] who insists on zoom
meetings when a simple [ __ ] email
will suffice everything he communicated
here would have made more sense by text
especially since that's exactly what he
does next anyway this 30 seconds of
table setting requiring someone to use
multiple utensils for one meal why would
you ever need three forks or three
knives why is this island england
tonight's feast
is prepared as a token of gratitude do
you know what really says thank you a
hot shower and some medical attention to
a mortal wound and to encourage you all
to perform even more splendidly in the
final game because nothing encourages a
person to be entertaining while fighting
to the death for the satisfaction of
creepy millionaires more than a heady
mix of indigestion and exhaustion
he's over there junhoe decides to
inexplicably blow his sizable head start
by standing in clear view for all to see
the plot can only protect you so much
sir no one will be seated as these two
men play a game of staring with stakes
wasting ammo you have him cornered why
is this shot police
put down your weapons you got that
[Laughter]
the coast guard will be here soon i
don't know where the f did you come from
dude i didn't even know which way to go
and how did he get here so quickly his
orders were to bring junho to him so why
isn't he chilling on the beach earning
20 percent you barely get any signal
around here
i don't know what you tried to send
but i doubt it went through call me
paranoid but i feel like if i was
running a secret death island of murder
games i'd want slightly more assurance
than barely any signal and i doubt it
went through when talking about the
dissemination of incriminating evidence
one chamber must remain empty and one
must be filled with a blank which means
that there's only
one bullet left in your gun this is
actually true but there's no rule that
says he isn't allowed to carry extra
bullets you know in case he has one of
those fancy guns that aren't single use
one bullet's more than enough to kill
you exactly it's not like juno would be
dumb enough to shoot him in the shoulder
or something
damn it not eating your vegetables i
hear that's the key to a long and
healthy oh never mind who the hell
are you
[Music]
chino's actually only 10 percent as
shocked as he should be considering this
is the actor that was referenced by g
yong in the gongu episode sorry squid
game if this is like pepper potts
referencing how much she likes rdj and
the sherlock films and you know we'd
send that [ __ ] you know why
valid question why would frontman only
shoot junhoe in the shoulder clearly
wants him dead so why assume that a
non-lethal bullet wound in the following
fall into the ocean would definitely
result in death now i'm not saying that
i'll give all the sins back if juno
returns in season two but if he does
that's exactly what i'm not saying i
would not do
so this strap we saw earlier was purely
decorative if the goal is to give the
players some tlc and rest before the
final game to encourage them to be as
entertaining as possible why give them a
very valid reason to want to stay up all
night who's gonna be happy to fall
asleep in this situation how is a
three-way fight between sleep-deprived
players going to be entertaining even
worse what if two of them are killed
here and now and the vips never even get
to see the final game this episode is 67
these three staring at each other and
considering the episode is as a whole a
good 15 minutes shorter than the
previous ones that leaves about three
minutes of actual interesting plot
development and by interesting i mean
not interesting at all putting a knife
in your pocket blade up and i would
finally start paying attention
thinking money makes you a good father
pulling a knife out of your pocket
handle first after putting a knife into
your pocket blade up don't do it
that isn't you
you're a good person at heart well
thanks to you we'll never know now will
we because if gihan needs to be reminded
he's a good person to stop him from
stabbing a man in his sleep he's
probably not a good person
[Music]
saybach was never going to be a threat
in the final game so wouldn't it make
more sense for songwoo to keep her
around guillen would likely take some
stupid risks to protect her that song wu
could take advantage of killing her now
just gives gihan even more reason to get
bloodlusty this sequence slow motions on
for all the some time bafflingly there
isn't a single doctor nurse or talented
butcher that's able to help the front
man with his bullet
[Music]
wound playing a love song while roasting
human remains over an open fire
[Music]
well that was
so much anticlimactic
now there's your problem now wipe
yourself off
you're bleeding
that gun of yours holds five bullets
i know what you're thinking did you fire
six shots or only five well i tell you
the truth and all this excitement i've
kind of lost track myself
[Music]
and do you know what you're gonna do
with all that money once you get out
i'm gonna go to disney world
what happened
tears but a scratch